DC's Titans has earned a mostly positive
review from fans and critics but DC
universes flagship series is far from
perfect these are our picks for the 5
best and 5 worst things about Titan so
far Titan season 1 introduced villains
the nuclear family who quickly
established themselves as being funny
creepy and absolutely vicious the
nuclear family of the comics were
somewhat different they had a different
origin different powers and never
actually locked horns with the Titans
the first appearance was 1985 s The
Outsiders number 1 where they were
actually all robots
despite their safe suburban appearance
these villains are truly brutal on the
show going so far as putting dub in a
lengthy coma through matically their
perfect adversaries for the Titans just
about all the Titans are either orphans
Runaways or both while the sadistic
nuclear czar a twisted parody of what
society would have us believe is a true
family sorry kids Ryan Potter does a
good job as gar Logan aka Beast Boy but
fans of the character have still been
frustrated by how limited his powers
have seemed so far in the comics gar can
turn into just about any kind of animal
it doesn't matter if the animal is
native to earth or even if it's ever
existed yet for all of titans first
season gar only uses his powers to
change into a tiger Tigers have always
been my favorite ever since I was a kid
the show is a justification for gars
limited skill set but it still takes
away from the fun of wondering what
Beast Boy will change into next the
situation is starting to get better
though in the season 2 premiere shortly
after the Trigon possessed Titans beat
gar to a pulp we see him change into a
snake hopefully we'll see some more
variety in the episodes to come current
Walter's first appeared as Jason Todd
aka the new Robin halfway through Titans
first season and it wasn't clear if the
young braggart would be a regular
feature but Jason shows up in the season
2 premiere and by the end of the episode
he's joined the team at Titans Tower in
San Francisco you're the new Robin
present and accounted for babe hey Jason
adds an unstable element to the Titans
he's hot blooded he doesn't respect
Authority and doesn't play well with
others
and comics readers know that he's a
ticking time bomb Jason was famously
killed by the Joker in the classic death
in the family storyline returning years
later as the lethal vigilante red
hood Titans is pretty light on action
and when a fight scene does kick off
it's often a little underwhelming Titans
is good at more grounded action like
scenes have Dick Grayson taking on a
bunch of thugs in an alleyway but the
team now includes a girl with demonic
powers a boy who can change into deadly
beasts a fighter comparable to Wonder
Woman and a super-strong alien who can
hurl energy blasts at her folks so why
are so many fights just simple
hand-to-hand combat it's rare to see
even more than two or three of the
heroes fighting together granted Titans
is still just a TV show and you can't
expect big-budget special effects but
what's the point of a superhero team-up
series if we don't get to see them all
teaming up for a giant fight despite
their silly costumes the story of Hawk
and Dove is proven to be one of titans
most compelling arcs some of the best
episodes of the first season focused on
their different motives for becoming
crime fighter's Hawks struggle with drug
addiction and doves brief romance with
Dick Grayson hopefully we'll see more of
the pair in the second season and beyond
DC's most powerful superheroes exist in
the universe of titans but it doesn't
always feel like it all the big names
are sidelined and the longer the show
goes on the more conspicuous their
absences feel it's a big house it's
funny that I only ever see two of you
it's almost like the studio couldn't
afford another x-men we've already seen
the show's creative team struggling to
explain the absence of characters from
the expanded universe and not just the
ones in capes in the season 2 premiere
when Hawk and Dove go to the Wayne
mansion looking for Batman Jason Todd
has to break some bad news
Bruce is halfway across the world with
the rest of the Justice League Alfred to
wait Alfred - why would Alfred need to
go on assignment with the Justice League
they can't make their own tea it may
have a frustrating cliffhanger but the
season 1 finale was by far one of titans
best episodes
Trigon subjects dick to a nightmare
vision of his old mentor finally
snapping and going on a rampage
throughout Gotham City with dick being
the only one who could stop him which he
does permanently the decision to give in
to his most violent urges puts dick
under trigons control dicks adventure in
the illusory Gotham is an example of how
Titans uses the expanded universe to its
advantage we only see glimpses of
characters like Batman Joker and
two-face but in this episode at least
it's all we need to see the only a list
superhero we've actually seen on Titans
is Bruce Wayne who shows up for the
first time in the sea
and to premier you'd be hard-pressed to
challenge Ian Glen's talent especially
after his memorable turn his draw more
mods on Game of Thrones
but it's questionable whether or not
he's right for this particular role for
one his American accent isn't the most
convincing thing in the world and at 58
years old he also seems just a little
bit too old to be playing The Dark
Knight Glen isn't too old to play a
retired Batman but one who's still
active with the Justice League that's a
stretch in the comics Dick Grayson
eventually comes out from Batman's
shadow sets his Robin costume aside and
rebrands himself as the hero Nightwing
as Nightwing dick has a darker less
Peter Pan s costume and he eventually
leaves Gotham to find his own stomping
grounds in the fictional city of
Bludhaven Titans has been teasing this
development since the first season and
it seems like just a matter of time
before dick adopts the new duds toward
the end of 2018
Titans showrunner Greg Walker confirmed
that the season 2 premiere episode
Trigon was originally meant to be the
season 1 finale he claimed that this was
changed because he loved the idea of
ending the first season with a
cliffhanger and starting the next with a
bang but after watching the episode you
might wonder if the actual reason was
because the culmination of the story
just isn't satisfying in Trigon almost
every hero besides Rachel and gar do
nothing to contribute to the main
villains defeat most of the heroes get
possessed then just stand around looking
possessed
Rachel insists she has to predict from
possession before fighting Trigon but
it's not like she really needs his help
how does she defeat the all-powerful
demon we've been told can destroy the
universe she walks up to him says
something snarky unleashes her power and
just kind of vaguely wins how she beats
him isn't really spelled out at all so
much for that storyline check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]